on this week's food truck diary we got
Harrison Rogers the UFL CEO and then my
man UFC Pride Legend Rampage Jackson I'm
feeding them tasty barbecue let's go
[Music]
fellows welcome the crew is back the
crew is back we're here to get a little
update on all things UFL and then
obviously Rampage I mean you've been
here a million times yeah yeah I love it
here yeah I mean we used to work here I
gotta pay you more I know man I pay you
more I mean start paying anything
anything you know I want to be a thick
boy because I'm I'm thick but you're
getting a little you're a little less
thick last time we saw you bro I know
you made fun of me last time and I was
like I was in my legs
you look good though man you went you
went to Thailand and got uh with some
working with lots yeah and then you just
decided did you start deciding to lose
weight in Thailand I didn't lose a pound
in Thailand because the food well yeah
because you're running from ladyboys and
I was running from the ladyboys I should
have lost some weight no I didn't lose
that much weight and telling what I said
what I did though I kept I kept the
momentum going and because I had started
training with one of my good friends
he'd been my friends for a long time
he's like a fitness model then when I
came back he I went back working he said
man you lost strength you lost strength
so I started working really hard and he
put me on his fasting and no sugar and
no carbs in the waitresses happened 40
pounds that leave I think like 20 pounds
yourself yeah you trying to yeah
that's how girls do it girl
no man 10 but anyways I'm trying yeah
and everything is things are often
rocking with UFL man I can't wait to get
into it yeah there are things that are
moving shaking especially with Rampage
so man when when we have time after this
food I don't know if we get into the
details here or we can get food first
I'm starving I know you starving Daddy
I'm not supposed to eat till five
o'clock I know but I'm gonna pretend
it's five o'clock oh well fact we'll put
a thing in the month yeah
sorry Sean yeah yeah so let me grab food
and then let's get into all this juicy
all right let's do this
all right
[Music]
what's up brother good to see you again
man thanks for having us I'm stuck
between the big bad wolf and the three
little piggies three little pigs are
number one item for sure all right the
most popular one all right let's do I'll
do the three little piggies little
piggies also do the uncle house tacos
you wanna do that with brisket pulled
pork or barbecue mushrooms uh brisket
um and then I'll do the the street corn
street corn and the creamy potato salad
potato salad
easy you you know I got to go with that
that big bad wolf because I'm I'm I'm
aware really fitting for you yeah yeah I
gotta go with like green with that one
yeah I got I gotta go with that and um
what's up what's up with those tacos
yeah yeah I like pulled pork yeah
yeah pulled pork tacos we can put some
extra pulled pork on there and come be
pulling all that pork and putting it in
my mouth wait that doesn't sound right
yo get that meat in your mouth dude no
no [__] off I'll do the three three pigs
don't have anything on barbecue sauce
and mustard barbecue and that's not
spicy though it's more sweet than
anything perfect thank you sir anything
else that's it brother
but now I'm on my way stayed up every
single night and hustled every day
[Music]
all right boys let's dig in
your your coach is gonna be so excited
he's gonna be mad at me because you're
you're doing 24-hour fast yeah so you
stop eating at 5 p.m yeah I'm breaking
my fast it's one o'clock I know sorry
dude you know blame it on me I'm blaming
you hey he's lucky I like you I won't
break my fast enough I know man I
appreciate it listen you know I love it
I break my face yeah of course she's
like yo meet me here and have these
chicken tenders or whatever ask my son
don't be having some hot chicks
dogs
so we got just for the the viewers just
now we got Rampage son here right
correct me Raja right yes sir boom
what's up man how are you doing you got
your pop's here yep yeah now you came on
my radar I was in the UFL you had your
your fight there was not too long ago
you won the fight he's a amateur fight
and then I'm with you I think it's time
to go pro but your dad seem to be a
little bit of a hater on that
yeah I mean I understand where he's
coming from though because uh especially
after that fight
um I do have a lot of stuff I still need
to work on yeah and from three minutes
to five minutes is a big jump even
though it doesn't seem like huge huge
difference so you know I I do agree with
but at the same time I'm getting older
too you know and it's it's starting to
it's starting to become you know harder
especially in the gym like everything is
starting to move at a different pace now
so how old are you 23. I mean not that
old man yeah
I feel like I'm being an older man my
back hurts damn it 23. I feel a little I
feel though Dylan from the training yeah
do you feel pressure having Rampage I
mean straight up UFC Legend Pride Legend
as your dad and then they fall on the
same footsteps Michael Jordan's son
sucked that basketball yeah see when I
hear that you know I'm like oh you know
it gets to me sometimes but you know I I
do you know do my best to
to
to not let that bother me you know yeah
it's a lot do you feel pressure a little
bit so stop yeah it is tough how come
you never told me anything about that
you don't talk to me I do
not because see I I do stuff to to not I
don't like thinking about it to be
honest I really don't like thinking
about it it's tough It's not like you
know
he's just some dude you do a good job
like you tell me y'all you don't you
shouldn't feel no prayer you tell me
that all the time so I keep that in the
back of my head so that doesn't really
help does it you know I was I wish he
did everything I told him I walked in
the room the other day
some had some big fat white chick in
there spread easily eating her ass I got
it from him though you see he totaled
himself shoot dude
[Laughter]
um
but yeah for you besides eating big
girls asses
um I mean it has to you're 23 did you
know you're gonna go down this route
like obviously your dad has some
you know you got one of the best
fighters to ever do it in your corner so
I'm sure you felt like that this could
be a good route for you to go down I
mean don't get me wrong with your dad's
Rampage Bruce Lee [__] Fedor it's
it's a tough gig man no matter who you
are you know it's just a tough way to
make a living I'm sure you see it from
your dad's perspective too yeah
um I always enjoyed like because I used
to go to the gym when I'm sometimes I
always used to enjoy that you know I see
how hard he worked and stuff and I was
like I'm a big big fan of like hard work
especially like you know I liked working
out anyway I've been been watching them
train since I was like seven years old
or even younger but that's when I really
started saying like Okay this and I knew
it was going to get big because you saw
it like on TV like they were starting
even back then like like iCarly it was
big you know it was big it was getting
it was getting traction uh Here Comes
the Boom all that that's true like
iCarly's doing like arm bars and [__] my
son watches that show yeah
executing arm bar yeah yeah I couldn't
believe it they even they even buried
him on there too oh they did right yeah
that's right they did what they paired
you and
yeah they use somebody that um to mimic
you like howling yeah for real yeah give
me a chance we gotta take him to court
take it up with Nickelodeon let me know
how it goes for you yeah but
also what made your dad different too
obviously exceptional fighter but he had
a personality too like your dad's name
in comic all I do is hanging with Comics
she does want to play speaker you know
like he's great but then that
personality on camera too like I'm sure
you've seen some of his like pre-fight
interviews post flight interviews like
viral I don't know if you watch that
stuff I I do it pops up on my uh on my
feed a lot it's it's funny like the
thing is I don't need to watch it
because I got him at home you know and
he cracks jokes 24 7. I can't stop
laughing even though you know it's it's
fun you know he's a fun guy he's a
really cool dad you know how come you
don't listen to me
he didn't ground you for eating ass
that's cool my dad would have grounded
me man
I call him doing that
brand new yeah yeah at least at least at
least this girl though she sounds really
chill for you know this whole father-son
conversations happening while she spread
Eagles she didn't she didn't get a shame
or nothing and he kept going like a open
environment that's a different world I
just closed the door quietly yeah
because for you
um what what advice did you give him
when he said he wanted to start fighting
right you know what I'm saying you can
only do so much if I'm going to be
honest I didn't I didn't know how I felt
about him fighting
and um he started wrestling
and um
when he started wrestling I was really I
was really proud of him because you know
he started late just like me like when
he was 17. and um okay he's gonna do
something positive then
if you want to start fighting and he
started hanging out with Antonio McKee
then I was like okay he he already chose
like the best coaching yeah with the
boys yeah yeah so I was like oh yeah go
ahead I'm I'm just gonna step back let
him Coach you and I just tell you some
of the things that worked for me yeah so
you try not to be overbearing right hey
it's tough man yeah I think that's what
I think that's what you where fathers
mess up a lot of times
they don't make it fun for me and
nowadays
they're like they're too much in their
face too much pressure yeah and that's
why I knew you're gonna have suppressors
but I didn't know he was having that
much pressure I stay away a lot I don't
go through a lot of the trainings you
know I stay away a lot and I just showed
him the government roll I show him a
couple of um defenses to uh certain um
MMA moves
running it coach McKee and he got a
coach named yl what's the yl last night
Watson yeah Watson oh yeah he found the
UFC yeah yeah the black dude tatted up
yeah yeah taller yeah that's one of his
coaches yeah yeah and he changed he'd be
sparring and moving around with with AJ
so I'm like yeah he got some great
people around I assume a lot you can
help him on like the business aspect of
it yeah I try to teach them that but
your dad signed some deals I don't know
what allowance he gave you as a young
man but your dad signed some deals so he
probably should have put up more money
for you you don't listen to him no deals
I mean life I mean he was one of the
main dudes you know with the Affliction
all that the extreme Couture tease the
monsters like not the nuts we got to
talking about those extreme Couture tees
in your last episode
well that's that's watering the bridge
though yeah
but it's really fun to watch you guys in
UFL specifically coming up because you
know we've had Frank we're talking about
Bella and it's I I don't know if I'm
weird I see the simulation I see all the
you know things connecting and maybe too
theological or whatever but with UFC
Legend MMA upcoming and these new
upcoming talents that are I think the
future on the future
promotion of UFL it's really cool to see
these Legends to Legacy to upcoming so
I mean how long can we do this though
because you got you got Rampage
you got Raya you got
um you got Bella you got Frank
Randy Couture's son fought I think we
can get Tito's son from ASU to decide if
he's gonna fight or not I mean Tito says
he didn't want him to and that he but I
don't know the age limit my son's seven
I feel like he'd be up for it
is a little too young to start but yeah
when you look at it it's like I don't
know it's gonna have some shares early
how many yeah
because because also it's tough too
because
you know fighting comes from the from
the streets man fighting comes from the
gutters that's what Tyson said I said
yeah you know you don't start fighting
because you have a lot of options
instead fighting comes in the street
right he looked at me with the most
intimidating goes no no fighting comes
from the gutters he's like not this it
comes from the [__] gutters he's like
I got a fighting when you know because I
had other options he said I don't want
to do that [__] so it's tough with your
dad being Rampage and obviously Rampage
grub your dad quit and grew up different
than you did right like fighting was an
option for him
obviously he's had a lot of success so
it's tough to instill that in you
because the reason he started fighting
probably different the reason you
started fighting that's where he gets
dicey I don't think he's I don't think
he's hungry as I was at 23. you're
you're fighting to eat you know what I'm
saying you're fighting to make a name so
it's just that that's why the pressure's
on you you know what I'm saying yeah but
you fight
with that pressure well you were I don't
know if you want me to say this but you
were in the back
nervous yeah for UFL too I'll be worried
if you weren't throwing up I throw I
don't I'm like do I divulge do I let you
talk about this but you came out that's
normal like that fueled you and it was
crazy no you never threw up well I never
threw up but you were nervous you can't
say you weren't nervous yeah nervous man
no it's normal but I've heard if I was
throwing up I've never I've heard of big
names for the throne yeah crying in the
back before they got don't let like
that's that's just a level up yeah I
thought it was normal that's an IQ like
you should be scared and we've talked
about on several episodes where you're
like I hated fighting people that were
scared yeah I hate fighting cowards no
no no no I know they're scared like that
yeah you put it I hate when people are
scared fight because you get an extra uh
boost of adrenaline that I don't get
because I'm not as scared as you are
yeah
Evans
he had extra [__] ass coward yeah Jon
Jones he came in I didn't say that
Richard shots my buddy too but [__] them
when I was fighting [__] them I lost to
them and that's something that you never
forget you know you don't forget like my
wins I don't think about those that much
I was just going off of the sound bite
that's yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
cause uh you know come in the cage
crawling and [__] and I was like what
the [__]
this department I wanted to kick him in
his face but I knew I was going to get
disquality yeah it's illegal my man I
know so I'm like but what do I do I've
never seen anybody do that me neither at
that time nobody's no one's ever come up
to you crawling yeah he was down like so
he couldn't kick him down yeah and then
Jon Jones try to take over that what
crawling out hey that's what he did no
that's his thing that's his thing you
know I started he didn't start it Jon
Jones yes oh Rashad did it afterwards no
no no no shots was different Rashad
would do some of it but John really took
it another level but it's also weird
with you fighting like as much
experience as your dad has there's
really no way to like
kind of articulate like getting like
dealing with those nerves like something
you have to figure out like you can tell
you don't worry it's part of the process
like this is normal but it's just you
with experience learn how to those
butterflies and anxiety getting it to
work in your favor you know like there's
nothing there's nothing anybody can do
she comes with experience you know yeah
what do you what did you think about
fighting on the same card oh I'm excited
for it are you guys an athlete they're
gonna find the same car we're announcing
it here right on thick boy what's the
plan yeah I'm down to do that I I want
to find like a good opponent we need a
good opponent uh heavyweight it'll be a
heavyweight what about your boy titties
scoot over yeah he hasn't fought forever
man me neither I haven't found three
years I know but you know I don't know
what he's do I don't know if he's active
you know I don't is there anybody else
in mind you know
me and Shannon but we're going to do it
yeah
I wonder if you do I wonder if you do
agree to MMA but he did say he would but
I'm saying with no takedowns like you're
just making promise to not take each
other down what the [__] how's that MMA
I want to slap him yeah true I like
slapping people he's big right like hell
he's bigger than me yeah he's a big boy
but I mean like he's like are you
slamming yeah I think he's like six four
six six yeah he's bad I met him
pick that up yeah yeah I'm strong as
[__] man I'll be a man one day I just
couldn't imagine
get you're not gonna try to get you in a
triangle though so you're not you're
gonna try to give me a [__]
but I'm think try to think of the free
agents out there it's tough man Sean
don't look it's tough with the free
agents out there I mean you look at like
pfl yeah
you know it's like these people chasing
UFC it's just it's top you look at the
Bell tours roster you know pfl's roster
It's just tough man that's why I said
teams show now that's gonna be a tough
sell man right I mean you guys have your
history from Ultimate Fighter 10 which
is right but what what 13 years ago
right yeah what if he get what if he
gets paid handsomely
Harrison's rich
I don't yeah I don't know dude not
anymore man man UFL and F3 was a big
lift but it's taken off now I'm excited
to talk about where you better say I'm
gonna cut you off no go ahead I mean
with this Vegas thing that we're going
to tomorrow
I was looking at the audience because
I'm super super excited I don't know if
you guys normally bring in the audience
with your eyes but get ready because F3
and UFL is going into enemy territory of
Vegas but you got to especially as an
energy drink yeah it's like crazy though
you're the Beast I mean and and people
are going to hear that and be like oh my
gosh they're already trying to fight UFC
and that's not at all like I'm excited
for UFL to be
a completely independent you know UFC
will always be UFC but UFL is going to
kind of be that
um
you know League we've talked about phase
two it's a totally different model we
now have franchises we have teams but
they take care of their Fighters it's
like an MBA where they have they don't
even need a union because they have
these Fighters that own a piece of the
company they make good money but they
also have health insurance they have
people that are actually advocating none
of this Jake Paul
sound bites and I Pro I I keep getting
told don't try to send out any I'm not
trying to pick fights or trying to call
anybody out but I just love that we're
actually doing what we say we're gonna
but yours is different though and not
defend Jake he's a buddy but what Jake
Paul and US Anderson we're trying to do
they're trying to do it on like a
different scale right because they're
they're trying to unionize the UFC
athletes yeah different and totally like
what you're doing you're starting from
scratch and those guys are coming in
yeah with rights you know what I'm
saying so what they're trying to do and
rally the troops there they're fighting
a battle that no one's ever won yeah and
that's why I feel like overtake
Afghanistan it doesn't happen yeah and
that's why I feel like it's it's kind of
like
an easy thing to say is because you know
it's an unwinnable thing it's it's like
I disagree I I know Jake well he
actually wanted to make a change and he
doesn't and it I I did too I was
involved in it when they hired the the
head guy that came from MLB the lawyer
to get all the fires together and I was
like oh we have the perfect team and
then once you get to the nitty-gritty
you're like oh this isn't happening and
I think Jake had good intentions and it
did give him a lot of clicks and stuff
like that and it was good sound bites
but I think at the end of the day
oh I think originally oh good but if he
keeps going with it now we know but I
think originally he's like I can make a
difference and then once you peek behind
the curtain you're like oh no no I'm not
gonna do [__] like it's just you you're
fighting a battle that yeah it's it's
sealed tight right now airtight so you
got to do it differently it's a
different battle you guys are like
totally shout out to you guys but you
guys are doing it right from the jump
thank you and it's expensive as hell but
you know the reason why they don't yeah
there's a reason but we're it's in the
Long Haul you know it's you have to be
able to survive the five 10 years to be
get an audience get people knowing that
you're not just gonna fizzle out and
that's what we're doing we're gonna do
it right and smart but
um you know these uh gimmicky things
maybe maybe we should jump on that
bandwagon and try to get a huge payday
just because I mean Elon
Mark all the Paul stuff it's like how
much money do you think these fights can
actually make and do we sell out and do
a gimmick every once in a while
yeah that's a tough road to go down for
for the for the UFC it's a it's a little
different I I see two sides of it as a
businessman like does it is it a gimmick
does it take away from the FC I I don't
know they're so established I just I
think they should do it and maybe Dana
White's involved but it's not under the
shouldn't be on UFC pay-per-view that's
insane but that's what those guys want
to do it just shows you if you're rich
and famous enough you can do anything
within the UFC fight space you can't do
it in the NFL NBA NHL MLB they're not
going to have it but UFC's it's a weird
kind of outlier where it's like we'll
entertain this it's a gimmick no matter
how you panic attack
it's for sure a gimmick but but it makes
sense
it doesn't make sense to have two guys
who can't fight fight and sell on
pay-per-view that's why I don't think
you should be on as you see Ben I think
Dana should be involved but do it
somewhere else
I guess yeah and do it so it would be
huge money you don't have to be it could
be still being an octagon in a cage or
something but Dana can promote it and
just somewhere else and not call it a
UFC you know
yeah like the UFC's brains behind it but
it shouldn't be like it shouldn't be the
main event over like Izzy do places or
Robert Whittaker or you know like these
legit Fighters you know this like right
part of me is like man that's so [__]
up it's like you know how hard I work to
get in the UFC man like the amount of
that's insane these two Rich dudes who
can't fight just because they're rich
and famous get to jump as a main event
so part of me feels that way yeah part
of me as a businessman because that's
gonna make all the money in the world
and then they go but we're doing for
charity that's fun for them to say and
act like they don't need money the
amount of money that the UFC will
generate off this is insane
Elon Musk I'm sure that they'll get the
money to the church but I understand
exactly what he's saying so they don't
have to do it on a regular UFC card and
make it the main event they could even
bring up some some young talent that
they got and just throw them on on there
people are going to come to see the main
event you just slap some I guess the
argument for that is like so let's say
it's the biggest pay-per-view of all
time whatever they think it does 20
million pay-per-view bites which I
totally disagree with but let's say it
does I don't know 10 million
the argument with that would be like
okay well those people tuning in do we
stack the card below them so people get
more in tune with our stars and
hopefully they stick around oh yes you
know so it benefits those guys yeah
yeah but so I'm gonna get a lot of hate
for this but I think if UFL gets a
bigger name and Harrison isn't just like
who's this wannabe saying something but
I would love to box Dana I'm gonna be a
lot of hate for that but he he was a
boxer right yeah Dana Dana kick your ass
here
I'm not trying to Jack right now I'm not
I'm not trying to say like anger too
he'd be a problem but if we're gonna do
a gimmicky fight if if UFL gets big you
know obviously F3 like we become a
contender and it's like not oh this
guy's punching up Harrison's trying to
get noted when it's established I would
love to say I'm a wannabe fighter I have
those three amateur fights that I
shouldn't even talk about because back
then it was smokers it was glorified
it's a fight it's a fight you're one of
us and so I feel like I am at that that
stage where Dana was back when he was
trying to call out Tito when he was like
I want to be a fight whatever I don't
know if that's what he did but I'm just
saying that's how I feel I'm like I get
that itch of like oh I see all these
people kicking you know ass and I think
I could do that and I'm totally totally
not it's not reality but if I can get
one of those itches done with a Dana
gimmick boxing match Daniel's give me a
tough one to go for my bad
if you're saying there's a lot of money
there and I would say and I would be
serious all that money would go to the
fighters of whoever won like I'm sure
where's your wife let you do it
if it got me in shape
but I'm sure so like we call them
gimmick fights and we're headed back
that way it's like a lot of like you
know back in the even the Bellator days
when they did like the Dada 5000 Kimbo
Slice the horse Gracie fighting you know
whoever the Ken Shamrocks like those old
heads it's a weird thing yeah it doesn't
seem like there's UFC is gonna be fine
because they're so established but for
these other leagues that do it doesn't
seem like there's any longevity in it
doing like those weird kind of gimmick
fights yeah but that's me and Tyson for
UFL because there's some big names out
there that you could sign they're not
gonna be around for long boots you can
get eyeballs I know and that's right
your challenge is you want to bring in
young talent but nobody knows who they
are even though they're great Fighters
totally but so it's like in eyeballs we
got a business so you can see why people
they're like yeah let's toss in like you
know no I can't wait for people to tune
into UFL three in August because it's
our semi-finals for our grand prix some
of these fights that are now rematches
because some of the fighters have gone
up through our feeder League Freedom
Fight Night who have beat each other
kind of a controversial knockout like
holy crap this guy should have knocked
him out now they're they're you know
facing each other in his semifinals who
they have both beat the same person now
to get there it's really cool that these
talented Fighters are going to start
getting the face time that we need them
to have for us to start getting notice
you know their successes our success and
that's how a promotion should be it
shouldn't be like exactly it shouldn't
be like Fighters take it or leave it
this is what we're like no let's grow
together you guys are legit shareholders
of the company obviously our success is
your success but we need to invest in
you as well and uh this first Grand Prix
is gonna gonna show that I love it
well hopefully see a fight with you guys
on there yeah that'd be cool I can
Corner my son and then he can Corner me
if I'm like the main event did that big
white girl in the corner too
he's earned it bro
well she all she had to do was later
it's work
you guys got a lot going on man you know
it's fun that's exciting we need to find
your opponent yeah
when you find a new opponent too
got a lot of work to do yeah it was a
lot of work he's had a couple that just
you know look at it and then they say
uh-huh at his level that happens all the
time it's it's tough to get people to
sign up for especially if he had he has
a name then they know his dad they're
trajectory trains with yes some kid
training his mom's gym he's like God
damn I'm not ready for this that's the
main reason why I decided for him to go
pro now because uh I was going to
actually had like 10 fights but it was
getting harder and harder to get people
to fight him for free
the pros they're not gonna back out you
can control a little bit of who he's
fighting too because he had it's uh your
dad tag this it's a it's a marathon not
a spread man you know yeah take your
time there's no rush especially at 23.
no rush yeah
but you gotta get you got a good Mentor
here man one of the best
so appreciate you guys man hopefully
hopefully this barbecue didn't mess up
your night you messed me up I'm sorry
man
he looked that big girl up so yeah
oh yeah man after the fight I was so
happy I just ate that's all I did hell
yeah I should have done it though he was
gonna listen to me I told him I
appreciate you guys man no more barbecue
yeah sure thank you for having us I
don't get in trouble with your dad yeah
appreciate you guys all right thank you